foreign
[Music]
good morning thank you all for
prioritizing this versus the LL Cool J
private after party last night I
appreciate it apparently it wasn't very
good anyway so don't worry about that
um my name is Marcus Oliver and I lead
the Delta transformation practice in
Google Cloud Consulting
um phenopsis obviously a core part of
our practice because it's you know
crucial for for successful
Transformations
um cloudfinops has become a critical
capability for critical capability set
for anyone interested in the cloud and
like many aspects of the cloud
automation is a key part of that
strategy
today we're going to look at phenox
Automation and particularly how that can
be used to drive and reinforce culture
change
so there are many challenges that
companies face to implement robust Cloud
Finance capabilities for example
establishing granular cost visibility
accurately budgeting and forecasting
Cloud costs and deploying effective
controls
but I think what companies find the most
difficult challenge is to change human
behavior
whether as individuals or as teams and
organizations
we all have a strong tendency to stick
to customs and processes that we're
familiar with and many of us myself
included quite frankly change is hard
we're going to hear for some experts on
how they've achieved this change
so to introduce the Fantastic panel we
have today I'd like to pass the bet on
to my colleague Bruce Warner who leads
the office of the CFO practice and is
also a cloud Finance practice lead here
at Google
thank you Marcus and good morning
everybody and welcome I'm really excited
to be here today as we talk about
Automation and how that can be used to
support a cost aware culture and drive
fin Ops and across the organization so
we are very fortunate to have with us
today three leaders who have been deeply
involved in their respective
organizations cloudfinops strategies and
automation initiatives today we have
Carol Rodrigo and Chris so first let's
meet Carol Carol's the director of cloud
Finance at Palo Alto networks Carol
please tell us a little bit about
yourself and the fin Ops Journey at Palo
Alto networks hi everyone happy to meet
you I lead our Cloud Finance team at
Polito networks my team is responsible
for reporting forecasting and planning
for cloud cost and also optimizing on
the rate side including optimizing cut
coverage and negotiating with the cloud
providers we also work very close with
our engineering teams on optimizations
and sharing best practices and helping
them quantify the impact of some of the
things that they do
in the last five years we've started our
migration Journey to the cloud and this
started with us expanding our cyber
security product portfolio and now most
of our products are actually hosted on
the cloud in the last two years we've
spent a lot of time on automating
visibility and alerting and now we are
very focused on automating
tooling to enable our Engineers to take
more action so I look forward to sharing
more and thank you for having me great
thank you Carol it's really nice to have
you with us today
next I'd like to introduce Rodrigo so
Rodrigo is a site reliability engineer
and finops manager at globo
Rodrigo please tell us about your role
in The finops Journey at globo perfect
I'm glad to be here representing the
awesome Global professionals my mission
at Global is leading fine Ops SRE and
Cloud programs Global is the largest
Media company in Latin America it brings
together open TV beta TV channels
digital products and services for
entertaining and informing almost 100
million people daily in Brazil by 2021
we decided to partner with Google Cloud
to run our workloads accelerate
Innovation and our digital
transformation
and we were also using different Cloud
providers for specific needs with
non-standard processes and governance so
we decided to embrace finops and
reaching and uh
this developing our own tools through
automation to have to to help us keep
the budget under control both
technically and financially
in this journey people and processes are
also very important we were able to work
with a multi-functional finops team side
by side with Cloud users to harness the
cloud spend without slowing down our
Cloud Migration by the way we migrate
within 18 months 400 groups of
applications composed by thousands of
microservices and we really were able to
keep this under control and I'm glad to
be here to share with you our learnings
that's terrific Rodrigo and thank you
and we're really excited to hear more
today finally I'd like to introduce
Chris so Chris is the vice president of
site reliability engineering and
platform services at Equifax Chris tell
us about your role in The finops Journey
at Equifax thank you I'm very grateful
to be here and represent all the great
colleagues I have at Equifax so my name
is Chris Frye I currently lead
reliability and platform services for
Equifax Workforce Solutions I've been
with Equifax for more than 16 years and
for the last three years I've had the
pleasure of leading our local Technology
Group on our finops journey much like my
colleagues on the panel here we're
undergoing Cloud transformation and
Cloud migration and so we've been
undergoing that Journey for the last
four years
over the last three years in our finops
journey we've been progressing if you're
familiar with like the finops foundation
maturity model we're progressing along
that path right so we're somewhere
between what I would say is Walk and Run
and most of the work that we've done
this year has been really focused on
unit cost and unit cost economics and
I'll talk more about that later in the
first year we probably did what a lot of
you all have done already which is to
tackle that low hanging fruit and find
those big expenses and cut those out and
in the second year we really spent a lot
of time on forecasting and working on a
shared cost allocation and
accountability in our organization we
are highly collaborative across multiple
technology groups and finance right this
is um we cannot be successful without
all of our partners internally in the
company our service delivery is also
highly matrixed in our organization and
thus in order for us to be successful at
controlling our costs the entire
organization has to be successful at
managing this costs and we'll talk a
little bit about that later and I'm
excited to share some of those learnings
with you that we've learned over the
last three years
that's terrific Chris and thank you and
welcome and welcome Carolyn Rodrigo your
organizations clearly have a wealth of
experience in cloudfinops and Automation
and I'm sure the audience is eager to
learn more today
now in case you are new to cloudfinops
let's start with some foundational
Concepts first off what exactly is
cloudfenops now while the term finops
has been around for many decades
as core Finance operations processes it
takes on a whole new meaning when
applied to Cloud technology
now at Google we see cloudfenops as
merging of two Core Concepts
first is a governance and operational
model that spans not only the finance
organization but technology and business
as well doing things such as
establishing effective cost visibility
cost controls and driving efficient use
of resources
creating metrics that demonstrate the
value of investment in Cloud technology
and integrating with budgeting and
forecasting processes as well
that is combined with a cultural change
one that drives broad organizational
accountability for costs and of course
that is an absolute key to achieving
value from your investments in Cloud
technology and achieving the ROI that
you seek on your Cloud Investments
so cloudfenops addresses both highly
technical considerations such as
resource pricing and Architectural
optimization strategies as well as very
Financial ones as well such as the
planning and forecasting process and how
the business measures the p l impact of
investment and technology and the value
that creates for the business so a
comprehensive fin Ops strategy must
address a governance model that spans
traditional lines of business leverages
cloud-first principles and uses
automation strategies to scale impact
so what kind of cultural challenges are
common for companies to face when
they're moving to a cloud-based
environment
so the approach to how Legacy
investments in Data Center Technology
have been managed can have a large
influence and capex heavy data center
environments a sunk cost mindset can be
very pervasive
technology infrastructure from servers
to storage and networking infrastructure
while they've been previously purchased
and ongoing consumption of those
Resources by engineering teams Bears
little to no impact on current costs
not surprisingly these types of
environments can have limited
organizational visibility to costs and
related metrics and Leadership while
they may maintain a point of view that
visibility to those costs should be
limited to a narrow executive audience
now compare that to a public Cloud
environment where consumption of cloud
resources directly drives incurred costs
and you have a dramatically different
environment
so whether determining architecture
sizing resources determining the
appropriate pricing model for use of
cloud resources those will all have a
direct impact on incurred Cloud costs so
how can companies pivot to this new
model and drive that large-scale
organizational change well Marcus is
going to share some thoughts on that
Journeys and at the heart of the
large-scale change is a set of
principles that will guide through that
transformation
so Cloud embodies the agile organization
from a more Dynamic approach to
technology development to how budgeting
and forecasting are approached
fundamental to cloud is a variable
consumption model that has the ability
to expand and contract resources and
related costs as demand varies
so this requires a new level of
collaboration and partnership across I.T
finance and The Business
an accountability model where
application teams are responsible for
the efficiency and value realization of
the resources they deploy
so finally blamelessness is a core
principle that we Champion here at
Google some would say that if an
organization is not you know making
mistakes they're not taking enough risk
and so-called mistakes are the
opportunity for everyone to learn
to learn and improve on existing
processes and capabilities and to do so
in a way that focuses on the issue and
not the person
so one of my favorite definitions of of
culture is is how do people behave when
no one's looking
it's the touch points it's the core
behaviors and how teammates actually
respond to them that Define the
company's cultures
so a key goal of phenox capabilities is
to enable their engineering nearing
teams to take action on cost by
providing real-time actionable and
insightful data
to achieve that an organization must be
open to sharing the cost data it has to
be visible visible we need visibility
and that data must have a level of
granularity so that Engineers can
quickly associate that data with the
applications they're responsible for
it must be actionable
one of the other things I like most
about Google is this is is the fun right
making work fun and I think that
gamification of phenopsis is a great way
to do that
throw out a challenge to your team so
you could drive the biggest cost savings
that month see the passion and energy
that that can result from that
combine that with an atmosphere where
those achievements are celebrated and
shared and you'll have the groundwork to
a continuous learning organization
so you'll hear from Chris a little bit
around some innovative ways that that
they're doing at Equifax where it's
gamifying and celebrating the success
you'll hear from Carol on on how Palo
Alto alone Palo Alto networks is uses
continuous learning and sharing and
you'll hear from Rodrigo about enabling
Engineers to take action at globe
so now that we've set the context we set
the principles and the objectives
let's dig into the details
so Carol let's start with you can you
share with the audience a little bit
about the types of cloud for not to
automate automation uh efforts that your
team has been developing please
yeah there are many ways that automation
has helped us drive finops culture at
political networks first we automated
visibility and alerting for example we
aggregated Cloud costs across our Cloud
providers into one standardized
dashboard and we automated the cost
allocations so now this enables our
company speak one language when it comes
to Cloud costs across Cloud providers
and it provides a one place for the
Business Leaders to go to see their
Cloud costs real time
we also built some slack alerting where
it can alert on anomaly and budgets and
that helps Business Leaders remediate
earlier
more recently we've been starting to
automate execution as well for example
we've built tooling to automate our cut
purchases and also slack alerting where
Engineers can click a button and shut
off idle instances
we are also now experimenting with doing
Advanced analytics or Predictive
Analytics to see if they could do a
better job on forecasting and also on
Cut coverage recommendations
so maybe let me share a few examples
so the first thing we did was we
standardized our cost definitions to
help Drive functional accountability
so what we did is across the cloud
providers we had a same set of cost
definitions as you see here and we broke
down the build cost into cost components
where engineering teams have control
over and cause components where Finance
team has cost control over
this is all now automated and it
provides better accountability and
visibility
to started to create that framework I
imagined it created some tension in the
organization what did that process look
like how did it work as far as getting
everybody on the same table and an
agreement on how costs should be
allocated definitely change is never
easy as you mentioned so when we first
came up with the the framework a lot of
people that we worked with especially on
the product teams were like this is not
the cost that I've seen and why is it
this way and so I think it was
definitely a process educational process
so we did go team by team we showed them
how our costs mapped to their cost so
they understood where the differences
were and we explain to them the reason
why we need some standardized definition
otherwise we wouldn't be speaking one
language at the company so I think it
definitely takes time for the cultural
shift but I think with education and
Clarity on the objective of why we're
doing this we were able to get them on
board sounds like it takes a good dose
of time patience and collaboration to
get there
let me show you another example so here
is a dashboard that we built for the
engineering teams this is engineering
use case so in this example for gke
resource we show the configuration so
first the engineering teams need to
understand the current configuration
also the utilization of the resource and
also what is the cost impact of
different recommended actions that they
could take
and I think by we did this for both CPU
and memory and this is a real-time you
know automated visible visibility
dashboard for the engineers
um and I think this really helps enable
them to take action no you know the
what's the configuration and then what
what is the impact on Savings of some of
the actions that's recommended to them
common shared resource in many
organizations and I can imagine that was
also a bit of a change in a shift for
the engineering teams to think about
their respective costs so can you share
a little bit with us their reaction when
you first deployed this type of
dashboard yeah when our Central
engineering team first showed them this
dashboard and similar other you know
other tools similar with for other
resources I think the First Reactions
was the engineers were actually very
grateful they were very grateful that
actually they finally had this ability
because I think a lot of people want to
do what's right they just don't know and
with all the cloud costs and all the
priorities the engineers teams deal with
we want to make it easy for them we want
to make it visible and easy for them to
know what to do and what is the impact
and help them prioritize the um their
actions so I think this actually they've
been very happy and grateful to embrace
and now it's all about figuring out
their prioritization and how does this
compare to some new feature that may be
building and I think that that's where
helping to quantify the impact really
helps them on the prioritization part
next we're going to hear from Rodrigo
about some of the efforts that he's
leading at globo
hi sorry we focused first on
organizational alignment and visibility
by automation we ensure that every cloud
expenditure had an assignment manager
and team responsible for that costs so
with this visibility we bring budget
spending shared cost allocations and
optimizations opportunities to managers
and Technical teams also this helped
managers understand their own costs and
really technical teams explore available
opportunities to improve efficiency in
that moment we also helped the POS
understand how to forecast their costs
and to meet business demand and also to
keep everything under control they look
at dashboards and work on efficiency
uh what were really good in our
situation this kind of discussion uh
recently is part of
important kpis for Value streams areas
so this also bring collaboration to the
table and help Empower
finops adoption at our company
so after ensuring visibility we worked
on organizational alignment sorry after
ensuring visibility we work in parallel
on efficiency and alerts as well as
providing apis for allocating shared
data
let's talk about efficiency we can
automatically identify and manage your
scale using standard Google kubernetes
functionalities through our own past
called suru however applications can't
at true must also handle certain spikes
in demands with more than 20 times
higher than the normal peak in less than
one minute in our case because we
we work in a media component and we have
access based on breaking news and also
reality TV show moments in these
situations they Standard Auto scaling
waiting times doesn't work in and do not
it's not sufficient and we had to
combine different techniques to avoid
performance issues and also waste our
solution was to pre-warm our
environments using
programmatic scaling based on time
Windows as we Define it as Flags this
works well when we work when we
understand the possible time interval
that we may receive the large amount of
traffic
we are also exploring new ways to to
improve efficiency using machine
learning with these insights we are
trying to predict the demand and scale
environments in advance it it is
still helping us to find out good
balance between efficiency and
resiliency this last two groups of
capabilities helped us to break down
sales between teams and create new ways
to explore
opportunities to improve efficiency and
work together in innovative ways to save
money
here you can see our overall high level
design our environment is designed to
ensure that projects are creating the
cloud using Omni API we are a
multi-cloud environment and we have to
ensure that when we create a project we
really know who is the owner these
platforms ensures the the projects
inside have the right architecture
standards security requirements and
governance as default Omni API is
integrated with our itsm system too and
also with Erp
we unified the way we collect the
building data into a standard raw data
set where we used to allocate shared
costs and
work with apis to really share with the
teams their data
we also receive key performance
indicators from Google kubernetes to
provide recommendations
golden signs as an example for being
packing
comparing usage with the actual
provisioning size so these
recommendations help us to drive
efficiency also
bi's tools are used to spread
information to different personas in
inside Global and we we have a way to
receive new forecasts from the teams and
also to
reallocate costs when we when someone
figured that the is not responsible for
that cost
so uh Rodrigo
um in what ways has this automation
strategy uh really impacted the global
organization can you talk about some of
the results some of the uh the the the
the impact that that you've been seeing
yeah automation has helped us to create
a consistent data location that is very
important and techniques to start
balancing the efficiency with resiliency
because we need to keep the
the application is running even if we
have a large amount of access so it's a
hard work but we are doing well and
let's talk about the results
we successfully kept our budget under
control in 2022 in a year of our
migration with less than one percent of
variation this was to the accountability
we created with data and also with the
techniques we could share with the
company
showing them indicators that drive the
the opportunities for efficiency also
thank you Rodrigo these performance
statistics are a strong indication of
the progress your organization has been
made particularly in a highly Dynamic
media-based environment so congrats to
the team on the excellent work next
we're going to hear from Chris
who's going to talk about the experience
at Equifax
hey thank you so one of the first things
I'm going to talk about here is
something that Marcus mentioned earlier
related to culture
we recognize and reward our run rate
reductions or other efficiencies so in
our centralized team probably like in a
lot of your centralized teams you often
identify the inefficiencies and you ask
product teams or Engineers to take
action but of course we do the same
thing but we don't do all of that right
we expect that our product teams are
finding those inefficiencies and fixing
them without even our input but we do
want to recognize and reward that so we
have those engineers and those teams
record those savings and those wins and
we just do that through like a Google
form that even records that in a sheet
and then our Central team will go back
and validate at month end that those
savings are actually achieved and then
by recognition we have you know several
calls but we have a monthly Meetup with
all of the stakeholders related to
finops and our products and we call out
the top two winners from like the last
month month on those run rate reductions
and those efficiencies and we also give
them you know rewards in our internal
Bravo point system so that's one way
that we kind of like crowdsource and we
get everybody engaged in Saving the
second thing that's similar is forecast
accuracy is very important to us and
very important to our finance Partners
so we look at actuals to forecast and
then we in the same way we reward the
people who have the closest actuals to
forecast right I mean that's very very
important to us
um the other thing just related to
forecast is as we progress through this
journey over time we found that
forecasting does take a good bit of
effort from our teams it initially was a
lot of plugging numbers into
spreadsheets and we're now exploring
ways to automate that to produce those
forecasts centrally and to save some
time
the second thing that I want to mention
on here is moving from anomaly detection
to alerts to actions
so this is just maybe an example to walk
you all through so logging can be a
large source of cost in the cloud I
think you all probably know that and
oftentimes you might have an engineering
team that leaves on debug level logging
where they run some sort of large load
test and that generates thousands or
tens of thousands of dollars of logs so
we all you know in the initial stages
you find that through anomaly detection
right you might see that the next day
where you might see that the next week
whenever you get the large bill right so
what we what we've done is in that
particular example right you pivot from
anomalies to looking for what's actually
the signal what and alerting on it right
so we will set up through automation for
all of our containerized workloads
alerts around log volume so think about
like 10 megabytes per second over 10
minutes right so if you cross that
threshold then we deliver alerts to our
platform team into our product teams to
say hey there's a problem right and so
that's something that we've done through
automation that just comes out of the
box in our platforms but we'll take that
even one step further now and what we
will do is we'll automate deletion of
the workload in non-production
environments when it triggers that alert
right because even one hour or two hours
of excessive logging does cost us quite
a bit of money the third thing I want to
talk about here is that we have a highly
matrixed organization I mentioned that
earlier with a lot of interdependence
between service is and we can't deliver
cost-effective services without the
support of the rest of the organization
and so we centrally collect cost and
also unit data and we do that in
bigquery and this allows us to
illustrate the cost to deliver our
products and how they're built for
multiple services with multiple
responsible parties and then that
transparency allows our team and our
product teams to focus on the most
important areas when it comes to
reducing costs
um and then and so and then what this
enables um say a dependent organization
to not just see the cost that they
charge back to us as like one large
bucket of whatever that dollar amount is
for a service they might provide like
billing or authentication but it allows
them to see how that breaks down into
the actual delivery of the product so
this next slide will illustrate this
capability so this is a mock-up here of
a visualization in looker Studio off of
data that's in bigquery uh just to
explain some of the data a bit uh it's
the unit cost breakdown for a product uh
graphed over the month so the y-axis is
like a total spend in dollars uh the
y-axis on the right is the unit cost and
the unit cost is also represented by
that black line so the stack bars here
show the different components that make
up the shared cost so like the black bar
might be the direct cost that a product
team controls about the production of
the unit and the other bars might
represent up other shared services that
we get from other parts of the
organization so like I mentioned earlier
that could be something like
Authentication or billing right so um a
view like this enables all the teams all
the teams to understand where to apply
focus in run rate reduction efforts
that's quite a journey I've been driving
Chris I'm curious did you experience any
pushback or resistance across the
organization as you drove these efforts
and uh if you did how did you approach
dealing with that that's a great
question of course there is a pushback
across the organization
um
if uh
whenever we're looking into the areas
that are driving costs right
um especially when they're outside of
our organization uh the other
organizations the other organizations
don't like Outsiders necessarily coming
in and surveying and telling them how
they're running their operation and how
things are too expensive right so
there's a natural human friction there
whenever that happens
um but we have to get past that right we
have to be collaborative because
ultimately you can see the cost to
produce the goods that we sell you know
made up in that graph
and often then what you will see in the
organization as you make this journey as
everybody transitions to this model
suddenly you will have Finance partners
coming to your organization with their
handout saying hey you owe us this money
for this monthly bill where it wasn't
you know as previously as Bruce
mentioned earlier it was all cost that
you maybe was never seen
so here's just maybe three things about
how we can overcome that um have
transparency in the costs like shown
here right it becomes everybody's
scorecard right the cost to produce the
unit is everybody's business and
everybody's responsibility in the
organization discuss units right and
discuss unit costs so contrast these two
statements if I say
I don't know let's say 200 000 a month
is too much for authentication does that
sound as good as if I if I say something
like four dollars is too much for a
login right so contrast those two
statements when you're working with your
stakeholders if you can break it down
into something that's more meaningful
that helps and third maybe I it helped
us to establish a chargeback policy so
something isn't a great simple as an
agreement to do like a showback for one
month before a chargeback comes really
helps reduce the friction because no one
likes to show up no one likes to receive
an unexpected bill from another partner
right and you don't even have a chance
to understand the bill or understand the
unit costs or understand like how to
help them optimize that charges they're
coming to you so have them come first
for a month to show and explain the cost
before it actually maybe is a true
charge back in the next month
okay
uh have one final question I think for
uh for you all so
um for each of you can you share one
piece of guidance that you can provide
for the audience as they begin their
Journeys
Carol
um so I would say you know automation
visibility and tooling is just the first
step
um to you know really get adoption of
phenops culture I think requires one
executive sponsorship this is a cultural
change it can't happen without executive
sponsorship and the second is I would
say have a strong phenops leader that
can influence without control without
Direct Control so they need to be able
to do the right stakeholder management
position the right way and so have a
spinop leader that has that capability
yeah data drives Behavior accountability
and also awareness efficient efficiency
is the consequence but success depends
on how you care for and support your
team in their daily based decisions
as a pronounced practitioner we need to
bring collaboration to the table not
judgment
so also be transparent in every cost
allocation decision because it can
really impact the way you treat your
people inside and adapt things when
necessary because cloud is evolving and
processes needs to evolve as well
um echoing similar sentiments here
phenopsis a multi-disciplinary journey
if you're in technology like I am make
sure you have a good Finance partner or
good and a good sourcing or purchasing
partner right show and share the data
and have clear targets and then reach
across organization lines to help
achieve the results that are most
impactful to the business
great thank you all very much very
interesting insights so we'll have some
time for some q a so if you've got
questions feel free to line up at the
mic
and at the uh while we're waiting for
any questions to queue up uh just a
quick question like what's next where
where do where are you all going next
based upon your significant uh you know
Carol what's next on the horizon at Palo
Alto for us it's uh you know the
adoption of so we have a lot of
visibility and tooling and great as well
now now it's to engage the team by team
change the culture you need to educate
them and work with the product team so
we're in the process of going team by
team it'll take some time fantastic all
right I see we got some a line at the
mic so okay first question
question for Carol you demonstrated a
dashboard where you had gke costs
under utilized over utilized CPU cost
Etc so that was that dashboard out of
box or you had to do some engineering
changes to get that
no it was not actually a lot of the
tooling is built in-house and we did
evaluate all vendors I think for us a
few considerations one is the amount of
cloud spend we have it'd be too
expensive to vendor secondly it's Unique
like each of your environments products
the way that it works is very unique so
I think it worked better for us to
customize it for our internal needs
thank you
the product feature request for Google
is
Association of labels and and costing
reports for example if you look at AWS
there are tags and that you can run
custom reports based on just tags
Department business unit applications
app owners whichever way and our ours is
a global organization and inability to
run those fine detailed reports just
based on labels is just limiting us
uh yes so we're aware of that
um historically Google has invested in
label-based architecture we're now
pivoting to tagging as the Strategic
capability we have a very close
partnership with our billing and cost
management product team which is a
robust product pipeline to introduce
those capabilities across the product
Suite so stay tuned that's coming we
understand the the need and we're
driving development there thank you
appreciate the feedback next question
hi I'm prashanth Devi I work for one by
Toyota so thank you all the panelists it
was a great Insight today so my question
is to Rodrigo
um so for I mean the architecture that
you have shown it looks great fantastic
so do you guys use any tooling apart
from
um what is natively available in the
cloud providers for the multi-cloud
course visibility as well as kubernetes
course visibility
that's why my first question and the
second one is
the data feed that you have shown is it
a kind of daily feed or is it a kind of
monthly and what you do with the app
sheets and the uh that piece which is
not very clear in the description
we choose to build our own tools because
when we figured that we would migrate a
huge amount of
workloads to the cloud the way the
solutions to manage Cloud costs were
based on a fee of our total cost so the
better way to us to address this
challenge really was building our own
tools and we use the Google
functionalities with bigquery scheduler
Cloud run to code our applications and
really work on that situation to bring
this solution to work and the second
question we about the timing we received
the data we receive the data as the
cloud providers enable it to be imported
so in a daily basis we show all of our
data with with the consistence
about the yesterday day you know so this
way we treat this this challenge
and the app sheets and the the top part
of the architecture that was not very
clear
so maybe I can connect you offline yeah
please thank you let's talk
hey I'm also curious about the tags and
labels like when you have multiple
resources multiple teams and maybe even
multiple projects under different
organizations is there a way for you to
check if
or impose some kind of tagging syntax or
process to actually check if certain
resources are not tagged or labeled
yes we can address that in a uh off
offline conversation here on the side
afterwards so if you hang around for a
few minutes happy to address that sure
thank you
hey good morning I know this on a couple
of slides you mentioned uh rewards and
gamifications so maybe a two-part
question if you could um elaborate on
that or some examples and the second
part is how manual or automated is that
process of issuing Rewards or really you
know your gamifications
yes I'll just briefly kind of cover
again and we can always
talk offline too so
um I would say that we are
all of the tooling to gather the data
around analyzing the rewards and of that
right that's all automated but we still
have a human kind of in place to analyze
it there's a lot of factors that go into
uh who you might select as a winner in a
particular month right because
oftentimes
um you can't necessarily go by absolute
dollar you might go by percentage but
that's our is our ask to the
organization to basically pursue uh run
rate reductions or cost efficiencies and
to find
um the the sort of the biggest savings
they can find we're also exploring some
other areas where we might try smaller
games like it might be a
[Music]
find all the reductions you can get in
non-production right or who can have the
lowest cost running over the weekend so
we're thinking about other games that we
can introduce but we just haven't done
that yet and and the aim is obviously to
bring visibility to that right the
organization needs to see that for it to
be effective and work so yeah yeah you
have to make sure that everybody plays
the game right and the rewards are
everybody everybody sees the the the
winners
all right thank you
hi this is tree from MX this is a
question to the panelists so in one of
the diagrams you showed that how the raw
data from multi-cloud is getting
normalized and I at the far right I did
see for uh dashboard view you had used
looker so was there any specific reason
or what were the key considerations for
you to use looker as opposed to other
cost management
tools was there any specific reason yes
as a
Google user look here provides us a way
to easily manage the data we can provide
for the teams in a way they can create
their own views also so we broadly use
local in in our company because of that
we choose to keep using these two to
share the informations okay much easier
to customize and yeah to get customized
yes in our case thank you and I'll say
in our case too I there's
we need a lot of customizations there's
a lot of different stakeholders and
there's a lot of different financial
data so I think we've just naturally
moved towards building our own
visibility to get what we want I don't
think that there's there's not a single
off-the-shelf solution that captures all
of the needs
got it thank you so much
good morning my name is Ryan with
dropping Technologies and I have a
question for Chris
in regard to the gamification of cost
reduction and for run rate reductions
are you differentiating between cost
avoidance versus cost reduction in the
case where you did right sizing versus
we deployed a well-sized instance at
first
so we do differentiate between that and
that's part of the analysis that happens
month over month when we're reviewing
but I guess I one of the things that we
have to be careful about is
um I think we're typically looking at
those run rate reductions versus cost
avoidance where we're not necessarily
analyzing a team who said like hey you
deployed the right size instance when
you started I don't know that we
necessarily have a game for that we're
probably more gaming that around our
forecast and our accuracy right so if
you've planned well through the
budgeting process and you know how many
cores you were going to use and you know
how big your database is you've built an
accurate budget and an accurate forecast
and then when your actuals fall in line
with that then that helps but yeah you
do run into some things where
you may be you may be thinking that
somebody might just over provision
intentionally to win the game but
frankly we're all too busy for that
right so but I I get we do have those
conversations and really they're just
honest mistakes when that happens got it
so it sounds like two different games
thank you thanks
hi uh Ron Curley with shipt
imagine a non-hypothetical company
that uh has got all the data that it
needs by accident in some respects just
due to its CI CD pipeline
um
but has no internal drive in the company
to dedicate Engineers to building out
what we already have the attribution is
there the showback is there the
segregation and all of that but there's
no drive to get more Engineers to
dedicate any more time and
take that
um we also struggle with that at the
beginning
um and one of the things is that one is
the executives need to see the benefit
and impact that this would have so one
of the first things we did is we
improved our cut coverage because that's
easier to to do and and finance that's
something I have control over so by
increasing our cut coverage we were able
to realize tangible and sizable savings
and so I can show my exact say if I just
had one person that looked at this
regularly and I had the dashboard of
visibility this is how much money I
could save and I think it makes a little
bit more real for them I think Finance
is also generally a good partner for
that because there's always a piece of
margin profitability management and I
think that can often be a driver to say
well what is the ROI and and why this
should be a worthwhile investment
it is super critical to have senior
leaders sponsorship and support
especially across technology and finance
and The Business
so we strongly advocate for a governance
model where you have a steerco function
that's overseeing finops it's got
representation from your CIO CFO
business leads and when leadership gets
together and as a team drives this that
models the behaviors and models the
change and the transformation for the
organization so it's super super
critical to have senior leadership
actively driving the transformation
so I think that's uh all the time we
have will be on the side here for
further questions thank you all for
attending thank you there are several
additional fin Ops thank you today and
enjoy thank you
foreign